all right oh yeah oh yeah
stream starting stream beginning alright
so now I gotta look for the law looks
like we're live yeah we are so I'm gonna
get the link oh yeah more and more noise
that's fine
oh there's a chat what's good all right
so where's my link then hmmm stream info
sup guys
oh man
well here what if I go to the live yeah
I'm gonna go to the channel hold on I'm
sharing the links of Twitter has it I
think Twitter would love to be on air we
go share copy/paste
tweet-tweet there it is alright there's
not that much to let either I don't
think
oh boy yes so we are live what's up
concept creator Oh concept creator yeah
that's good
the super chat is enabled it's up NASA
is streaming right now yeah so the end
of the Saturn Kissimmee is how you
pronounce it Cassini mission where that
that thing has been in space for so long
and it's finally descending into Saturn
after sending all that info back to
earth much appreciated Cassini uh
where's the can I point to it oh wow
look it's right under there that's the
thing that's happening right now
um yeah it's good I can so I can see the
chat and it's going extremely fast but
like this this number if do you see this
number it's it's 1,300 messages per
minute you see that in the corner there
I see that 1312 but super chat is
enabled and so I can see that - Rick
says go to bed so we've been up since
like 3:30 4 o'clock this morning timing
it out trying to see when to do this
live stream so much noise
but we're good now
uh-oh the basically the amount of people
that have subscribed in the last two
days meant that this I can now just
point to that this is happening a lot
earlier than we thought it would
hi hi hello hello I give away I'll talk
more about a giveaway in a little bit a
little little bit
oh man that's like a wagon the counter
just a rolling counter if you refresh it
maybe it'll like less ideally that's
good
what is up Gabe yes this isn't
interesting way to spend money I agree I
always wanted to ask why do you like
wireless charging so much I always found
it to be an inconvenient gimmick we have
reversible charging cables now should
know your opinion
wireless charging is not a necessity for
me but I do appreciate when phones have
it and I think it's gonna get a lot
better now that the most the best
selling phone in the world the iPhone 8
and the iPhone 10 are getting it it's
gonna show up in a lot more places which
means it'll get a lot better you'll have
longer range wireless charging you won't
have to put it directly just she goes
right on the mat well how does that is
that social base of all of the browser's
fault
it's probably the brothers well but yeah
what's up
did you try face ID doing a hands-on no
so the way they had it set up with the
hands-on area was they had a bunch of
Apple employees like all out there with
the phones and every single one of them
had face ID set up on their own like on
the phone they were holding so when they
handed you the phone to to get your
videos or to get shots or whatever which
was rare but when they did it it was
already unlocked and setup to that
person's face so I didn't really go in
and like take his face out and like add
my face I didn't really do all that I
would have loved to but I didn't really
get the chance but uh yeah I do I
haven't actually tried setting up or
trying face ID which is why I don't have
footage of it what do you think of the
v30 I made a whole video about what I
think it'd be 30 there we go
it's like in that window yeah been dying
to know how do you take a screenshot on
the iPhone 10 i I do think that a
screenshot on the iPhone 10 since it
used to be the home button since that's
not there anymore
they could do a pressure-sensitive like
press but I think they're going to do
the way iPhone does it now which is just
squeeze the phone one on the power
button one on the volume button boom
squeeze it screenshot makes sense right
what's up hello
way to go from Canada now you guys are
awake early I mean it's not that early
anymore
it was weird cuz we were here when it
was dark this morning at like 4:00 a.m.
like timing us out and there was a fox
right outside the door it's kind of a
weird sign Firefox well Apple sells more
singular phones Samsung sold way more
phones with wireless charging shouldn't
be much better already
so Samsung has sold way more phones but
a lot of those don't have wireless
charging the ones that do have wireless
charging the higher end ones
Wow mad people are unsubscribing then
the the war the galaxy note the galaxy
s2 those they're still really high in
volume but the iPhone is the phone that
so many of these these
third party manufacturers care about and
that's why all these these mo fees and
belkin's and everybody who's so
dedicated to making iPhone accessories
they're now going to make wireless
charging accessories huge achievement
marques I'm still have the freemen
you've inspired me to start making
videos to that is dope man appreciate
that I'm glad you did too
is periscope doomed no I think periscope
and Instagram live still have their
place but uh it's a YouTube's where it's
at
so we picked this number to go live at
because oh man Matt unsubscribes I see I
see you all now we've picked this number
to go live at because it was going up at
roughly like 400 an hour so now that's
at like 700 it'll take less than an hour
we'll be here for like an hour and we'll
we'll talk we'll talk give away we'll
talk whatever you guys want to talk i
phone things like that
yeah you should vlog your Tesla your
frisbee your life will be interesting to
all of us you're not going to be Casey
but that doesn't matter
I agree but I'm also like the vlogging
would take so much time away from this
that it's like almost not worth it like
if I vlogged I wouldn't do half the tech
videos and all the editing and stuff
that we do now because then you have to
edit the vlogs and it becomes this whole
thing so that's why I kind of stick with
the Q&A s and the occasional livestream
like this we are gonna hover at that 700
for a while cuz yeah we started is that
when we started the livestream when it
oh and then people thought oh man you
want to switch to my screen so you can
see if we can see that drop right now
so all of you lovely people
unsubscribing can see what you're doing
this is when we started the livestream
right around now it kept going up and
then it kind of disappeared and then
everyone's I'm subscribing again so
you're doing something also the lifetime
unsubscribes for the channel is now
pretty close to a million I think the
last time I checked which was like a day
or two ago the lifetime unsubscribes for
the channel is nine hundred ninety two
thousand so we're at a pretty clean like
five to one ratio of subscribes to
unsubscribes it's just gonna go so low
enough I'm not gonna talk about it
anymore
super chat hi marques from New Zealand
how does Tesla Model 3 compare to your s
what is the biggest missing feature from
model 3 I'll say in short it compares
really well the biggest missing feature
right now is probably the dual motor
option there's no all-wheel drive model
3 I think a lot of people who like
pre-ordered one and like northern states
and canada and up north would have
wanted that but yeah also there's no -
right behind the screen we're right
behind the steering wheel do you think
the next iPhone design will follow the
iPhone 10 I am kind of confused about
the next iPhone because maybe not
confused but I don't really know what to
expect because right now we have iPhone
10 and iPhone 8 first of all the naming
for the next iPhone do they get rid of
the bezel iPhone and just stick with
iPhone 10 and we just have iPhone 11 or
do we go iPhone 9 and new iPhone 10 I
don't really know what exactly is going
down do we title this live stream
because right now it says marques
Brownlee livestream okay probably I
could probably refresh it or change it
to yeah yeah let me get the link just to
make sure yeah it says marques Brownlee
livestream alright I'll change it to say
the road to five million and then enter
is it safe oh okay good looks like it
sweet all right cool um yeah we can go
back to one trying to read this super
chat like oh cool you got yeah what do
you think about India's new bullet train
I haven't been on it I don't know unsub
is for those who are trying to be the
five millionth sub about to unsub but
then you have more unsub's and then you
have two sub that's a really good point
yeah maybe maybe stay subscribed until
it's about to be no I'm not gonna troll
like that you guys are all gonna do it
anyway when you're changing your name to
MK be 4k not HD I've definitely
mentioned this before and a QA HD
encompasses 4k 8 k Ultra HD super ultra
HD it's all HD it's all high definition
basically high definition is a threshold
and everything above it is HD and 8k is
4k is so I don't have to change the name
anytime soon yep
forget iPhones how am pay for LGV 30 I
really liked it man I still have the
pre-release unit at the moment but I
made my video about the top 5 features
of it and it's pretty nice
iPhone is released another big deal is
pixel 2017 do you think Google and Apple
would have a close battle like last year
or Apple has one already there's a lot a
lot of different opinions about it
I think pixel XL to the XL specifically
because the pixel to the smaller one is
not going to be that state-of-the-art
iPhone competitor it's gonna be cheaper
but the pixel XL 2 will have the thinner
bezels will have the top notch specs
will have the first in line Android
updates will have front facing speakers
will have premium build will have one of
the best cameras I think in any phone so
for people who are you know phone
enthusiasts that's definitely something
to look out for and that'll be around
the end of the new smartphone wave for
the year and you can safely pick your
new phone after that comes out but yeah
it's a I do think it'll compete of
course I'm an optimistic person I wanted
to a few things did you have any updates
on lucid air and the red hydrogen one
love your quality congrats for 5 mil
thank you any updates on lucid err no
any updates on red hydrogen one a little
bit umm I did my hands-on video with
that red phone and a lot of people were
really into it basically when I was in
that room with Jim he told me basically
he was showing me the prototype of the
body of the phone and he had a separate
prototype of the holographic display in
a different unit without the red stuff
on it and he said within I think 30 to
45 days of when he was showing you that
he was like within 30 to 45 days we're
gonna have a prototype a phone with the
red back and the holographic display so
it's been that long now they now have
that prototype and they're now choosing
to slowly reveal little bits of
information about the red hydrogen one
including the actual display technology
which is really cool so that's out there
now
but yeah I haven't shown any more myself
since the video they're doing their own
strategic not leaks but like reveals of
things
that's just my video is just one of
those ways to show people the phone
which I'm really honored by what's up
girl thank you
are you going to take your pixel with
you to Cali well yeah of course if we're
if we're going to Cali for the event of
course all right it was about to be the
last hundred but then like ten people
unsubscribed over 30 why don't you make
videos in 60fps not that it's good now
just a thought I just I've never really
thought it looked natural like sir I
mean there's advantages to 60fps video
but I think there's more advantages to
resolution and clarity but I prefer
30fps when I look at 24 FPS video it
looks choppy when I look at 60fps video
it looks like just unnatural and weird
what were your thoughts on the Steve
Jobs theater what was the vibe of the of
the room during that opening sequence
honestly that theater was really cool I
took a bunch of photos of it from inside
I still don't know how they hold the
ceiling up I don't know if you guys saw
that tweet but the top floor of the
theater is all glass completely
surrounding you oh I got to find a
picture of it it's all glass and then
the ceiling on top of it Steve Jobs
theater oh yeah here we go you want to
show my screen right now there's some
good photos of like people who got one
to the event took pictures of it but
like you how do you hold the ceiling up
I don't know
so like inside each of those little
glass panes in between them there's like
a small like metal rod maybe an inch
wide but that doesn't explain holding up
the ceiling does it here's it this is a
good angle right here it's like a bowl
anyway it was really cool architectural
II it was like a quarter of a mile away
you could see down the hill was apples
giant spaceships circle campus it is
huge but yeah we were wondering as we
saw it like we were in it like how do
you back under nine hundred yeah we were
wondering how how how do you hold the
ceiling up downstairs as a theater
itself and it was really it was really
cool it was a quality theater antha
theater style like it's the stage at the
bottom the audience up above him the
mood was pretty chill during that
opening sequence it was the designated
of course the 10th anniversary iPhone to
Steve Jobs but ya know I think it was
pretty cool but you go to one again oh
my god 50 people's unsubscribe just by I
think when they see a number they like
they just hit unsubscribe or subscribe
or the chat there it is what do you
think about Samsung wanting to release a
foldable galaxy next year I like it I
mean I don't know how useful the fold
will be I definitely have talked about
foldable smartphones in the past but I
don't know Smyly reviews thank you to
five million thanks for the awesome
videos thank you for watching them I
haven't said that a whole lot lately but
the fact that there's so many of you who
actually come back and watch the videos
over and over again is the reason I'm
able to make them I wouldn't be able to
go to the Apple event if Apple didn't
see a value in inviting me there and the
value they see is I get to share their
product with you guys so thanks for that
thanks for watching the videos and I'm
glad you enjoy them that's what I want
to do 850
it's gonna be 854 uh for a while do you
think Bix people will ever be able to
compete yeah sometime just not now Bixby
has had so many false false positives
like okay Bixby supposed to recognize
like I'm saying it now and it's not
recognizing but if I say yo Bixby it's
supposed to light up and start listening
and that time it worked that's my key
will phrase is yo Bixby but sometimes
it's just lights up for no reason like
I'll be watching a video where someone
says like yo trick shots huh and it'll
just light up or actually the other day
I was editing and or not editing I was
typing before we're editing and just
typing and just lit up
and started listening like hello what
what did you say what I don't know it's
a very sensitive to its name even though
clearly I didn't say anything
beside the seems inferior to touch ID
for a variety of reasons do you think
Apple has started to prioritize design
over user experience form over function
how dare you yes/no form over function
is definitely a thing um I think here's
a question I can ask you guys this
iPhone 10 the way I think this went down
and why they went so all-in with face ID
is because they couldn't fit the
fingerprint reader under the glass in
time if this is true next year they
could put the fingerprint reader under
the glass but they still have face ID I
guess they don't abandon the face ID but
they can offer touch ID again and it
would kind of seem like you're backing
off because the way we saw the event
they're like all face ID is the future
you don't need touch ID anymore this
replaces it you're all good don't even
worry about it and that makes it seem
like all right we're done with touch ID
in the next like three years like it
won't be on any other there's touch ID
on this MacBook Pro there's touch ID on
the iPhone eight there's still touch ID
out there but they made it seem like
they're moving on like we're gonna have
face ID and MacBook Pros and face ID and
all the new iPhones
but I think if they can get a
fingerprint reader under the display
like is planned with many others maybe
uh maybe they bring it back maybe they
never abandon it in the first place and
we just have this little awkward pre
abandonment step thanks for all your
hard work Thank You Phil really Congrats
bro I make similar tech videos but in
Spanish hope someday to grow to be as
big as you that's awesome I've met a lot
of people I met a lot of people at the
Apple event who are like hey I make tech
videos like you but in insert country
here or answer language here that's
pretty cool hi from Australia pixel to
leeks dots I made a whole video on that
pixel to leeks thoughts
I'm currently lining up for the iPhone
810 days early to gain exposure to my
channel could you give it a shoutout so
you're like at the store now bro why
would you do that oh man Oh what just
happened Wow
Wow how many of you were on that and
button sitting on that button that's a
lot of you guys on that button holy
smokes yeah it's like a spike uh cool oh
that one a lot faster wow that went way
faster than I thought it would well geez
thank you guys thanks to the 400 of you
who just unsubscribes to go re-subscribe
oh boy that was crazy and it was like
it's exactly 8:00 a.m. right now so it
was like pretty much on the dot
that's funny what we did it will keep
going for a little bit so I was talking
about giveaways earlier oh wait
we're talking about giveaways oh yeah
yeah there's gonna be there's gonna be a
giveaway we I try to do I try to keep
giveaways few and far between because
when you do a lot of Giveaways you get
the crowd of people who's not watching
the videos they're just in it for the
giveaways so I do a giveaway every once
in a while when I feel like it's worthy
and I think this is one of those times
whoa you got five mil and cassini died
at the exact same time two great
achievements at the same time don't
butcher my name though I did yeah I
don't know if I said that right I'm
sorry
the Ksenia really died at the exact same
time cusine is the probe that was like
crashing into Saturn's atmosphere today
like the life yeah I'm pretty sure
that's also live right now well that
would be pretty funny I don't know if
that's true but I hope you're right man
that's funny the giveaway so yeah no
expected here's the thing I want to
announce what we're doing but because of
some recent announcements the giveaway
isn't right now the giveaway is gonna be
in a couple weeks and we'll make it
happen and it will be absolutely worth
the wait and it will be on the theme of
five million subscribers so that's
pretty much what I'll say so if you just
subscribed don't unsubscribe you're not
gonna want to this is something to stay
on board for but again I don't I don't
do a ton of giveaways I don't want
people to just subscribe for the
giveaway and then leave you know so I'm
like I'll make some videos in between
now and the giveaway and hopefully you
watch those Congrats on five mega subs
is that the prefix from million mega
thank you do you think it's too late to
start a tech review channel from zero
subs Congrats man well deserved
thank you I don't think it's too late
the thing about starting a new channel
in anything right now is you need a
niche so you can't just start a gern
there
tech channel that does the same thing
everyone else does and you need a way to
be unique in some way so bring your own
unique perspective your own unique style
your your own unique theme maybe talk
about certain types of technology or you
you do hands-on you dive really deep in
a certain certain rabbit hole that
nobody else talks about and starting
from zero subscribers is no problem
there because you're filling a gap
that's not already filled I think I see
a lot of people starting YouTube
channels now that try to do the same
thing that's already being done you're
not really you kind of are adding to
value for people but if people can get
the same thing somewhere else then they
will so I'd say make unique and make it
fun Congrats on five million keep up the
awesome work what do you do in your
downtime when you're not focusing on
tech it's pretty much always Ultimate
Frisbee it's we have the double practice
this weekend we have a tournament in a
week after that we're traveling for that
all the time there's a pro series
there's that there's the Club season
it's all its everyday bro man that's a
funny spike though
I don't even know to say it five
Millions it's social we're so like the
numbers on YouTube obviously YouTube is
like the universe it's like expanding
with scale and there's no way to like
fully understand that context but I
remember like a couple years ago back in
a day the first channel ever to hit a
million subscribers do you remember that
was does anyone remember who the first
channel was to hit a million subs a
million subscribers it was Fred Fred I
don't know if you know Fred the YouTube
channel that was the first channel ever
to hit a million so there you go
and it was like wow there's a million
people who not only are on YouTube and
watched videos but there's a million
people who have heard of this channel
and liked it enough to subscribe to it
and come back to watch the next one and
that's like a pretty big milestone like
it can't believe there's not many people
now there's channels with obviously 50
million plus subscriber I mean there's
one but the scale is insane and I would
have never seen a tech channel going
past a million let alone a couple
million so it's still kind of off all
striking all inspiring to me to see that
number and think that's a tech channel
but I'm thankful that there's that many
of you who come back to watch tech
videos I just I just to say I've been
watching and following you from years
before you even finished college back
when you're still trying to finally
groove I'm proud of you bro and keep it
up man thank you sir congratulations
excellent videos and work even after
five million year mein modest and
genuine no fluffiness or fakeness we get
marques thank you there's so many cake
emojis in this chat I guess that's a
good emoji for it
hashtag worth it still can't add a tweet
stuff oh man okay that's moving so fast
you get on one plus you get on one plus
uh probably soon I think that you one
plus will probably be pretty early on
the update train right near stock
Android quick updates oh but do you guys
know what this have you seen this before
this has been in the background of maybe
one or two videos so alright you've seen
like the the little tiny Android
figurines I've had in the in the
backgrounds of videos or like in random
videos you can buy a giant green android
figurine and it's a smells like paint
it's a cookie jar kinda or whatever you
want it to be piggy bank whatever your
deal is and I sent it to if you look up
on Twitter I am sloth or Timmy ham a
really talented artist I sent him a
MacBook Pro the black color MacBook Pro
also but this is the first project that
he did and look at the detail look at
the paint look at the logo so this is
like one of my favorite new like
ornaments to just have around pretty
sure I can wave and say hi yeah
making sure yet okay do you think it
could hold that probably not it's
handled too far away yeah but I can
definitely be happy there you go
now it's happy well yeah it's real I'm
excited for that MacBook Pro I think
that'll be sweet I think it'll be right
here in front of me on live streams
actually mm-hmm yeah definitely
expensive the iPhone 10 is an expensive
phone you got that right man I don't
know I don't know what to do we got to
we got to five million it's like just go
to sleep now thank you thank you guys
his iPhone 10 worth it
so my the video I just did the follow-up
video well that guy's oh I thought his
name was Brownlee but the last video I
did which was last night about iPhone 10
the follow-up that covers a lot of the
questions that people had about iPhone
10 so you did the first impression the
video you know we got our hands on time
and then I go back to the hotel I edit
it I publish it and then I go to sleep
and then we come back to the studio here
and I've kind of like just been
processing like all the things that I
was seeing there and all the things that
I felt about the iPhone 10 and so I
followed it up with that video about
okay is it worth it what are some
frequently asked questions so you should
definitely watch that video that's the
most recent video on the channel bottom
line I think it's people will pay extra
for the better iPhone and but but at the
same time I know a lot of people who are
on like the last leg of their phone
their screen is shattered it's slowing
down it shuts down randomly the
battery's dying and they just want a new
phone those people are just gonna get
iPhone 8 when it comes out and no
problem but I think they might be a
little bit disappointed when they see a
new iPhone
two months later that's better but also
not that mad when they see it's $1000
and they're like I wasn't gonna buy that
anyway
how much do you expect to earn from the
super chat feature I have no idea and
will it be good enough to buy iPhone 10
well I will be buying iPhone 10 anyway
because I plan on making videos about it
that's what I do but I'm glad I mean
super chat is enabled so it lets me like
get through some some slower boiling
questions because the chat is absolutely
flying do you explain tech to your
parents as well someone asks actually
mmm kind of not that much not as much as
you'd probably expect it's more like
like extended family during like
Thanksgiving and Christmas where it's
like hey my printer is broken again
would you mind fixing it and then the
next time it breaks they call you
because you're the last one who messed
with it that kind of thing my parents
are actually not bad with tech
especially my dad he's he works in IT so
he doesn't really need me explaining
things as much although I do sometimes
still have to break it down a little bit
greetings from I your Brazilian fans
thank you Italian tech youtuber here
inspired by you since 2011 just to say
thank you
hope I'll meet you anytime soon at an
event here in Europe MWC yeah I went to
MWC in Barcelona how long ago is that 2
or 3 em WCS ago and that was a lot of
fun but um yeah it's kind of like I have
to pick and choose when to go to those
cuz there's it's a big trip for like not
a whole lot of stuff but you kind of get
to walk around and see stuff it's like
it's like see yes but for Europe you
know I was just wondering this morning
in the last five years have you used any
phone consistently for more than six
months straight as your daily driver I
think maybe in the last five years yeah
I haven't in the past five years I was
thinking in the last year I think I
think pixel Excel I used for more than
six months because the way it kind of
works is you have a bunch of phones
released this is the time of year when
the most phones are released because the
holiday season is right around the
corner you want to get your product
offering on the table sometime in
September and October so that by the
time no
december roll around people are buying
gifts they're all buying your product so
September a bunch of phones August
October a bunch more phones and then we
get to January no phones get released to
like April it's like January February
March April
a couple things show up here and there
but that's the point where I usually use
a phone for the longest period of time
so I think last year I used pixel excel
from like when it came out October from
October till probably one the note or
the oneplus came out so a couple months
but yeah that's usually how it goes
that's the that's the drill with the way
phones work what is this hey from Mumbai
India quick question what if I what if I
blow scrolling what if I plan to make
videos but this stuff that interests me
smartphones tablets etc is the same as
most other people well my content and
style be enough to differentiate my
videos short answer is it has to be uh
because yeah a lot of people will make
videos about computers and tablets and
smart phones and headphones and cases
and stuff accessories so yeah it's got
to be the style and what you're actually
making and then how you talk about it
that differentiates you if the products
don't cake cake cake in HD appreciate
that man what advice would you give
someone who is pretty deeply rooted in
Apple ecosystem and looking into
switching to Android tit yeah if you're
deeply rooted the hardest thing to
switch really is iMessage I think
everything else is pretty close you
might not find the exact same apps but
if you use a lot of apple services
that's gonna be hard if use Apple Mail
if you use iCal like you basically have
to go into the web service export it
import it into Google and then go from
there
but the the reverse way is always easy
because you can access Google Calendar
on everything so going from Android
iPhone is super easy but Apple has
created this thing I don't know if you
know what it's called a
walled garden where it's really pretty
and beautiful and luscious on the inside
but leaving is really hard they call me
the mkbhd of India no not really but
you're an inspiration mate trying to
make quality videos like you Congrats on
five mil all the best for 50 thank you
for 50 150 mil Jesus you're awesome I
appreciate our content thank you do you
feel any lag in the note 8 I'm a bit
used to stock um
lag I don't think is the word there's
some occasional delay that you don't
feel in closer to stock phones but
that's just the way Samsung phones have
been for a long time man mm-hmm
what's the future of Sony Mobile I saw a
new Sony phone the other day and it had
a huge forehead and a huge chin so I'm
not really sure what to make of that
I don't I don't really know oh want to
talk about ok let me talk let me talk
about the color for the new iPhone
because I want to ask you guys this I'm
gonna read the chat as we talk about it
but the color of the iPhone 8 there is a
black space gray it's upright yeah
there's a space gray which is which is
like dark dark grey there's a silver
which is the one we've all seen which i
think is probably the least fingerprint
T looking one but they both have a black
front but with the iPhone 8 there is a
this gold color and almost everyone I've
seen said they like it I think it looks
terrible am I alone in this
am I the only one here comes all the
unsubscribes I I don't think this is a
good looking gold and we just had a gold
the oneplus phone in here a second ago
which is like an actual like kind of a
gold color when I saw this at the event
like I thought this was I who I actually
thought it was rose gold so I
on X let me show you my clip for my
video oh wait a second wait for it wait
a second okay so the beginning of the
video I talked about iPhone 8 this is
the silver with the glass back and this
is the gold and it looks like a I said
band-aid color I've said it looks kind
of like like a sandy sandblast kind of a
look the outside ring around the camera
and the side ring around like the metal
around the edge of the phone looks like
a copper sort of blush look but I don't
think it looks like a good gold what is
a chat saying not the gold or whatever
it is terrible not gold sand color I
want to send you with $1000 pink pink it
kind of does look pinkish I don't know
man I don't I'm not a fan either way you
know what I did was today this morning
at 4 a.m. I ordered the gold I ordered
it I'll take a second look at it I think
I ordered so I got a 64 gig gold iPhone
8 and I got a 64 gig Space Gray iPhone 8
plus so that's what I ordered for for
what I'm gonna be reviewing but yeah
those reviews are coming soon but yeah I
don't know I'm just not a fan of this
side of this like super gold color this
whole web pages is like pale I think
pale is the word that describes it I
don't know it's weird anyway yeah this
is this has been fun I am definitely
shout to the Philippines shoutout to the
Philippines this is fun I think we're
gonna do a couple more live streams or
the path over the next couple weeks but
there's a lot of videos coming up that
we're gonna be working on there's the QA
for September there's the note 8 review
September September there's all the
Apple stuff all those reviews
there's gonna be a bunch of pixel to
stuff when that comes out and then
everything in between all the I still
want to shake the Hasselblad stuff I
still have a bunch of other things to
work in a thousand people have
subscribed since we hit the milestone
but basically I just want to take a
second at the end of the livestream here
to say thank you thank you for for being
a subscriber I kind of talked about it
earlier in this livestream but like
again the reason I'm able to make half
the videos I've made in the last month
the reason I'm able to make them is
because you watch them so I try to give
you guys a bit of a unique experience
when you watch the videos
that's an evolving style I think about
evolving style all the time and that's
something we've been working on but uh
obviously a lot of you guys are
interested in the same tech that I am so
that's why we're showing it and it's
just been a fun ride I still remember
like it was yesterday the video that I
did when the channel hit a million
subscribers which was I was sitting in
my college apartment on the bed talking
to see 118 to 35 and the same mic setup
and everything and just like when I say
we're getting started like we're just
getting started
like I really mean we're just getting
started so that rings true yeah the
evolution continues but yeah that's
pretty much it all right stay tuned on
Twitter stay tuned for new videos and
for giveaway information since I know
you guys are all into that let me just
put this Android
it's too tall all right shout out to
everyone watch this this livestream
catch you back on twittering YouTube is
there a stop button over here you have
it okay
well let's hit it that